[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 181 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I am muck and I'm here with my colleague
muck hi mark yeah you mark mantle or
mark marchini attic merchandani that's a
good way to stumble through the facts
you know I feel like I've done a lot of
last name jokes here though
but I'm so I'm not gonna hold it against
you yeah you should you should you
should give me a great fit for a long
time it's it's it's a long it's a long
last name
so mark Mandel right sure know why isn't
it it's fine that's fine good excellent
I heard who we have joining us this week
so this is the television so this week
and I hope I pronounced her name
correctly but it should be Angela you I
believe so chatted with about the Google
Maps platform yes which I think a lot of
people are familiar with Maps in general
yep but in this case we're talking a
little bit more about like some of the
recent updates that have been done there
and how you know how you can actually
build some really really cool ideas with
maps right like it's more than just an
API yeah it's actually a new way to
approach thinking about building your
app or your website or whatever it is
yeah being able to use that local data
and the information that they have in
Google Maps within your own application
is pretty awesome but before we get to
that we've also got to talk about our
question of the week which in this time
will be a little bit about kubernetes
and what is helm so yeah I think I think
mark you were just like I don't know
this is Mark can you tell me so I was
like oh cool
I feel yeah I've talked about it before
and I've like understood it at a high
level but then it kind of came up and
we'll talk a little bit more about this
later but it's like what what is helm
and why hell why is it a thing cool
but yes before we get into all of that
we do have our cool things of the week
[Applause]
it's coming first this week ah excellent
so this week we had several cool things
I'm particularly excited by this we have
announced that Google has entered into a
definitive agreement to acquire a looker
it's a unified platform for business
intelligence data applications and
embedded analytics basically they make
really pretty graphs that are really
easy to understand it's really nice
which a lot of people highly desire
because I forget who was saying it
earlier but they are basically saying
you know there's a lot of solutions out
there for doing the actual analytics the
calculations and that's all fine and
dandy but at the end of the day
someone's got to look at this and make
decisions based off of it yeah and you
can't do that without basically being
able to visualize it or summarize it in
a meaningful way yeah so I'm very
excited about this this upcoming
acquisition so keep you updated on how
it all goes but yeah it's gonna be neat
I think it'd be really cool yeah
absolutely
speaking of in kind of new tools that
people can get their hands on here at
Google we've just kind of launched out I
saw a blog post earlier about the
version 3 of the translation API
that a lot of people are familiar with
right you you send in some text you kind
of send us some information and it
translate that well now with the new
version it's actually super cool because
you can kind of create your own glossary
x' so that's really helpful for business
specific logic and any terms that are
tied into what you're trying to do and
you can actually specify which model you
want to use so whether it's Google's
built-in models or if you want to
provide custom ones you they're making
it easier needs to train your own models
like Auto ml those kind of things it's
super awesome to kind of bring more
customization I think a lot of people
I've always wanted translation and it's
always been a little tricky because you
have like deep technical talks and yeah
everyone's kind of mentioned all these
products and translations like I don't
know what those are well now you can
kind of specify those and really get
some really cool results that would be
cool I can see a lot of use this case
for that games not that we make up a lot
of words when you have to go you know
fight the space I want to throw in brand
names I know that but I don't want to
get in trouble yes but there's anywhere
that you have a custom vocabulary I
think is always useful well in last
week's episode we talked about a Google
cloud networking in-depth article this
week there's a whole new one it's Google
cloud networking in-depth cloud CDN so
if you wanted to see basically how
Google clouds uses its points of
presence and its edge locations
to be able to cache and load balance
your information at the edge so that
people can get faster access to it and
also how you can use the cloud CDN
product and what features it has so that
you can take advantage of that as well
explicitly within your applications this
is actually really good little article
so it gives you some background and also
tells you a little bit about how you can
use the thing using Google Cloud HTTP
load balancer and how to configure it
and it started patents that you can use
as well for that I mean it's just like a
great place especially to start
understanding like if you're gonna throw
up up to something as simple as a
website yep or if you want to do
something much more advanced like huge
asset repos like understanding little
bit more of those CD ends is great and I
think there'll be more articles in that
same vein about like deep dives for
networking well at least if we've said
so on the podcast I have to do it I mean
now they're obligate that's it
we might get in trouble for that
speaking of last week actually we were
also talking about ways to save money on
yes Google cloud and a one that just
kind of came up again it's very similar
to the the talk we had last week so if
you haven't seen that go back and check
it out it's really cool you talked about
how to save money in this case those are
really really quick write up on how to
turn on and off compute instances with
functions oh nice so maybe if kubernetes
is too complicated for you like it is
for me then it might make a lot of sense
to do something a lot simpler
threatening on your workload where you
can basically just say cloud scheduler
which is basically managed cron mm-hmm
and you just say okay well at nine
o'clock turn my machine on and at five
o'clock turn it off that's super simple
yep maybe four lines of code I mean it
just basically has cloud scheduler
calling cloud functions and that's about
it super great to have and and the blog
post kind of checks out the details
there so definitely a cool cool simple
way especially if there's just something
you want to run once a day for example
yeah definitely extensible to write
because the business logic might say
whatever it is also it's neat stuff
finally I just wanted to make mention
unfortunately last Sunday we had an
outage there is an article that we have
posted up on the Google cloud bug
talking about the outage and the
incident that occurred including an
apology from our team as well on that I
had some details of what happened around
networking and at work capacity I will
defer to the blog post for specifics
there is a post-mortem that has been
said that we will be coming through and
we'll be looking into it further but for
those people who were affected we deeply
apologize and we will be working on that
further to make sure it never happens
again
always a good thing too
gonna read up on and kind of understand
like this is the real world things are
hard yep problems happen and so you know
our team obviously is gonna learn a lot
from it and you know hopefully people
out there can kind of read the details
and see why it happened exactly well
enough cool things of the week we've
gone through a lot there let's get right
into our interview right let's do it
so this week very happy to have Angela
you here on the podcast joining us
developer advocate for Google Maps
platform
how you doing Angela hi I'm well thank
you for having me thank you so much for
joining us today joining both mark and
Mark don't worry Mark's here yeah yeah
you're here too it's okay to talk to us
all about Google Maps and Google Maps
platform so before we get stuck in do
you want to tell us a little about
yourself and what you do here at Google
yeah absolutely I'm a developer advocate
I think we've had developer advocates on
the podcast before but really what that
means for me is I care a lot about how
the developers experience our api's and
as I'm out there talking with developers
and learning how they use our API is I
bring that back to the product teams and
I tell the teams what is important to
developers so that we can improve our
api's so that makes sense but let's
it'll take just a high-level step back
here just in case tell us what Google
Maps I feel like that a Virgin America
video the safety video is like for the
point one percent you haven't used
Google Maps Google Maps is really your
window into the real world we have made
a lot of investment in collecting all
the data of what exists in our physical
world all over the planet we've tried to
be as complete as possible covering the
oceans and the land masses and we invest
a lot in keeping that data fresh so
we're doing like 25 million updates to
our data a day and that's like updating
what business is at what location or
what's changed in a rose or there's been
some flooding all of that from just like
very tabular textual data about you know
listings but also visual data imagery
we've seen that we have satellite
imagery for overhead we have aerial
imagery for more of the low altitude
like 45-degree angles of buildings
and we have Street View you've seen the
the famous Street View cars driving
around on the students capturing really
at that address level and at that
building level what you see on the
streets and something I didn't know
before I joined Google Maps was not only
are there Street View vehicles but there
are Street View backpacks for hikers to
take you can see this site called Street
View tracks that you can see really
amazing views of the world of areas that
are really hard to get to like the front
face in Yosemite what's that what's that
big rock there's a big rock on a lot of
big rocks yeah yeah like that and in the
Himalayas and basically like you can
take a backpack you can take a tricycle
we've but we've enabled bringing that
street view 360-degree imagery
experience out to the most remote
corners of the world in order to give
you any kind of window you want to see
nice well as someone who grew up with a
physically bound paper like math that
made me drive around yeah we had one
called the male ways cuz he lived in
Melbourne Australia thank you so much
for getting rid of that for I think a
lot of people have used Google Maps I
mean hopefully to kind of replace some
of the older mapping stuff you know we
have this live like you were saying
you're pulling in a tremendous amount of
data but there's also a Google Maps API
for other people who want to kind of
pull in their own data that's true yes
so the API allows you to bring all of
that data that we've collected into your
own apps because everybody has their own
view of the world you know it's not just
like what is out there and what it's
public but you might care about where
are you and where are the things that
you care about whether that's from a
personal level like the people in your
life or if you track like your personal
property if that's moving around or if
you're a business and organization and
you want to track your physical assets
out there in the world so what sort of
things are people doing with the Google
Maps API what are some good examples the
really cool thing about working on the
Google Maps API is it spans everyone
from the individual hobbyist developer
to the largest enterprises because
everybody has some reason to be
interested in
Google Maps API is kind of often the
first Google API that a developer will
use just because as we're experimenting
we're learning new apps it's really
satisfying to pull in a map and have
that show up on your app whether it's on
web or mobile and it's one of the
simplest api's to use so in the
beginning individual developers can
start using location data just to show
things like where is my user and show
you that geolocation and then you can
broaden that to if you are an app that
wants to show the user certain things
around them that is not generally what
the regular Google Maps app would show
which would be a lot of businesses you
might want to show those specific things
like Evie charging stations or things
that are specific to what the purpose of
your app is that is really useful to
both tap into our database and or maybe
you have a custom database of your own
of where things are geo located that you
want to show around the user and also
for all different kinds of users you can
use the information of what is around
the environment or where things are
located to help users make decisions so
if you're trying to decide I have some
resources and where should I concentrate
those resources I want to find out where
are they needed you want to be able to
look at a map to find out where the most
action is in order to deploy your
resources to that location
like like a rideshare company first
exactly yeah is this limited to like if
I saw it like I know I've seen Google
Maps embedded on a web page is it
limited to that kind of view or could I
use the data in other formats like how's
this it like end up being a user
experience displaying a map is the most
popular way to use our API but we also
have a very rich database of places so
that includes businesses but also just
general places like parks or government
buildings and all of that rich database
is available through the places API and
then there's also the routes API that
gives you access to things like the
directions whether through driving or
walking or biking transit and roads say
you are that ride-sharing company and
you you're seeing a geolocation of like
one of your drivers and they're
nebulously like off of a road you can
snap it to a real road that they must be
a
and so all of those API is available
through the Maps platform so this
location there is kind of like how you
actually do routing and then moving some
things around I think we've actually
seen some pretty interesting use cases
recently of games implementing this to
create kind of an augmented reality
experiences yeah real world gaming is a
big trend it was really popularized by
Pokemon go and from that we have
expanded our API to game developers to
enable real world gaming where there's a
playable locations API where game
developers can identify where are good
places for people to have real world
interactions with things in the game and
last year there were five games released
using that API and there will be a lot
more this year but one of the most
successful ones is like Walking Dead so
like wherever you are you can see like
zombie attacks and you might have to
collaborate with other players in order
to defeat the zombies so these are
really fun things that you can do to
bring that digital experience and the
real-world experience together we make
sure there's a real zombie yeah just in
case it'd be nice to have a map saying
hey or go here go here yes if you want
your zombie API as part of the Maps API
that tracks all the zombies yes yes I
will definitely prioritize that thank
you thank you so much and it sounds like
you know there's so there's a couple
games that I'm using it what other kind
of trends have you been seeing if people
turn to adopt this and maybe create some
new experiences yeah you know we say the
problem of showing a map and dropping a
pin on it has been solved for 10 years
so we're really looking at what are the
new things that people are doing with it
you know obviously Mobile has been
bringing a lot of interesting use cases
to how people use the Maps platform
because geolocation around mobile device
is kind of critical information for
anyone that's moving around beyond that
I come from actually an IOT background
Internet of Things and this is the idea
of connected things not just phones and
computers but like any asset could be
connected to the Internet and especially
when those things are out in the
physical world they all have location
and it's very important to whoever care
to connect to that thing to know where
that is so we've seen a lot of
organizations both from the enterprise
to consumer realm be interested
in collecting data off of these things
mapping them so that they can show the
status of things out in the world and
maybe like many things in one area are
all showing the same state or are
trending one way and then they can make
better decisions based on that one
example that I saw recently was one of
our Google developer experts these are
external developers that have used our
API is extensively he has built a
prototype of tracking bike sharing bikes
and where they're moving around and he's
feeding it to a firebase database and
then pulling that database information
displaying it on a Google map and that
really shows the hotspots of where these
bikes are actually being used so then a
bike sharing company could use that data
and better deploy where their bikes
should be available because the worst
thing is if they were to put them off in
where they think the biking locations
are and nobody actually is trying to use
it from there that's a really
interesting project that you open
sourced it and it's out there on
hackster we can put a link to it in the
show notes but I think that's that's a
really great example of using IOT data
displaying it on a map and being able to
make a lot better decisions based on
that data I think you brought up
something interesting there to where you
were talking about firebase and the Maps
API given that we're the Google cloud
platform podcast who are you seeing like
interesting interactions or grouping of
technology with Google cloud with the
Maps API machine together like how does
that look to you yeah you know one of
the biggest trends that we see is the
big data visualization and we have a
really great code lab that shows you how
to query big data from the query and
bring that into a Google map so then any
data that you have that has a location
aspect to it can then be put on a map
and you can process really huge data
sets and be able to visualize them and
like really communicate and tell stories
about what is important in that data
that you just couldn't really surface
before one of the really interesting
things in Big Data
there's the bigquery public datasets if
you don't have your own data set you can
play with these public data sets and do
really interesting things just to you
know practice that muscle and see what
you can do in terms of data
visualizations of location-based data
but there's also an open source library
called deck GL that lets you build
really beautiful visualizations they
have all these layers that you can put
over a google map or interesting that
are specialized for different kinds of
data like if you had like the routes of
one of the public data sets is New York
City Taxi and Limousine services and
like all of the trips that the taxis
have been taking you can use their trips
layer to actually draw on a map the kind
of like time-lapse view of the trips
that all of these taxis were taking in
the time period it just works really
well and it handles huge datasets really
well so that's one of the things that we
announced at i/o with integration with
Dec da GL that we're really excited for
our developers to try neat very cool
were there any other kind of cool
announcements from i/o from the mounts
platform side we have a new SDK for
Android that we've put out for beta and
so we're really looking for developers
to try it out give us feedback before we
release the ga version what makes this
particular version for Android
particularly special we have actually
brought it out standalone from the
Google mobile core so that we can
release more frequently basically that
takes us out of their release cycle and
puts this on a more frequent release
cycle and there are a lot of rendering
improvements for performance so with all
those kind of use cases you were just
talking about none what people can get
their hands on it what would you say is
the coolest experience you've seen built
with Google Maps right like the
visualization sounds pretty awesome but
think about what's the next step I mean
we had zombies what's better than
zombies however you can toss on this I
think there are a lot of really complex
things there that are coming up in the
world and now it's possible to process
these really complex decisions so I'm
really excited to see you know what's
possible with ride-sharing companies are
really doing very complex routing with
us because they not only have to go from
point A to point B but consider all
these other stops in between and
optimizations and what I am most
passionate about is augmented reality
and seeing that go beyond just the
gaming applications of reality but also
how we see the data on the world around
us
overlayed so one of the big things in
the Android Google Maps app is the
augmented reality walking directions
which really helps people navigate
especially in big cities when they're
trying to orient themselves and I'm
going to reality arrows that kind of
show you exactly where to walk those are
very helpful and I see a lot of more
applications coming out for making those
kinds of experiences of showing you what
you're looking for actually overlaid on
your physical world if you wanted to
know kind of like the weird stuff really
whimsical things and one of the the most
whimsical things that has kind of stood
the test of time is this idea of making
an earth sandwich besides delicious I'm
sure so it's kind of it's kind of like
the idea that every kid has of like if I
dig a tunnel all the way to the other
side of the world where will I end up
birds are life that idea of you being on
one side of the world and what is on the
other side of this year those two points
on a globe are called Antipodes and
there are map tools that let you find
Antipodes of like from where you are and
most of the landmass actually the
Antipodes is in the water so there's
actually only I think four percent of
the world that you could have a land to
land sandwich and so these maps were
created to help people find Antipodes
like New Zealand has a nativity in Spain
for people to partner up and try to make
synchronize so that they can put a piece
of bread on one side yeah and so there
are videos document themselves putting a
piece of bread on this specific latitude
and longitude their partner doing it on
the other side and they have
successfully created an earth sample
which would be there's gonna be a lot of
disappointed six-year-olds yeah
actually with students one of the most
popular tools in the classroom is this
website called the true size because if
you are a map nur
you know that the maps were used to
seeing are very distorted to how the
countries actually layout on the globe
surface and so we are so used to seeing
these flat maps that our ideas of the
size of countries gets really distorted
and there's this interactive web page
it's called the true size where you can
drag a country to the equator or or
overlay it on any other country to
compare their sizes and see how actually
large or small they are what's what was
your biggest surprise when you tried
this well my biggest surprise is was I
didn't realize that Mexico is actually
as tall as the contiguous US and Canada
and Russia look really huge but actually
when you bring them down to the equator
they're much smaller I think Russia is
still like really big compared to other
countries but it's not as humongous as
it looks on the flat map yeah I mean
there was an update I don't remember
when it was but there was an update to
Google Maps the interface where you zoom
out far enough it switched from that
kind of standard Mercator projection
into the global one right yeah that is
just like it just switches to that
satellite view and it just goes to that
really true representation of the world
it's funny that you mentioned where
cater projection because there's a an
xkcd comic that actually types you based
on your favorite map projection and if
Mercator is your favorite than like
you're kind of just like a you know
lemming press you know what the word
Makeda is cuz i have no idea i took a
geology class actually interesting
question then so we were having actually
show conversation before he started
about all the different like latitudes
and longitudes standards or how you
track maps and stuff if I'm using the
Maps API do I need to go take like a
geology class or something like or
whatever it is yeah like do I need to do
that or does it make it simpler or how
does that work I think we've tried to
make it as simple as possible the
latitude and longitude I think you might
be used to seeing it expressed in like
minutes and seconds in this sexagesimal
wait but when you actually use like
Google Maps on your computer or on your
phone you'll see latitude and longitude
expressed in decimal way so it's still
gonna be like the same first two or
three numbers like 122 degrees west and
then instead of like having to convert
in your mind to like minutes and seconds
it's actually just decimal I just do
that conversion in my mind all the time
it's what I do for fun the formulas
written on the back your hand yeah yeah
no that makes sense and then so like if
I like all this sounds awesome and I
want to get started how do where do I
begin where should I go you know one of
the things that I've been really happy
about since I started is every time I
talk to an external developer they tell
me that documentation is great so I'd
start with our documentation we have a
ton of tutorials on there and we have
from the most simple like just show a
map to actually call a complex distance
matrix to figure out all of the
different times and distances of
multiple routes to get from point A to
point B and all of that is provided in
tutorials we have code samples we have
code labs to teach you some of the most
common tasks and all of that is out
there on github we have a Google Maps
organization that has a bunch of repos
for client libraries and utility
libraries so on the regular maps
platform we have the JavaScript API
Android SDK and iOS SDK and we have a
bunch of rest IP eyes but in our github
organization we have client libraries
for Java for node and go python and kind
of almost anything that you might want
to program in and so the process for
someone to get started just like any
other API they can just go to the GCP
console enable the Maps API get the key
and then start with any of those
tutorials right yeah and one of the
great things about us is that we on top
of any credits that you've already
gotten through Google cloud platform you
also get a two hundred dollar monthly
credit recurring for the Maps API so
your first two hundred dollars of Maps
API spend is free every month and so
that covers any kind of like
experimentation or development that you
want to do to just try things out before
you actually go into production and get
a lot
users so with that we try to encourage
and enable more of that experimentation
and playing around before it starts to
cost you anything that sounds great and
it sounds like so that's being charged
as a separate product is that billing
unified with the cloud do I need to set
up a separate account or anything like
that no it's all built into your Google
cloud account for any project that you
set up you just want to go into the API
libraries or marketplace and enable the
Maps API is that you want to use so is
there anything else that a developer
would need to know to get started it's
really self-explanatory
yeah we've we have a really great
technical writing team we invest a lot
in keeping our documentation up to date
and I personally am really invested in
keeping our samples updated and all of
our libraries and samples on github or
open source so we really encourage the
community to submit pull requests open
issues let us know if things are not
working for them or if they have ideas
for ways that our libraries could
perform better have at it
what's a demo you wish someone would
build hmm when a pet projects is with
augmented reality showing names and
ratings on buildings overlaid like right
around you because whenever I travel to
a foreign country and it might be harder
for me to understand or it's a very
dense place it can be really hard to
match up like an address to a building
that has no numbers on it right so
having that like kind of translation and
overlay to help me kind of figure out
where to eat or where is this place that
I was told to go to but I can't figure I
think that's kind of like my next big
use case that I would really love to see
yeah sorry like standing on a street and
you're like that place for three stars
that place is 5 stars right I mean you
you were just mentioning that earlier
they are and kind of the things people
thought with it the i/o app for people
who went to i/o you actually had
augmented reality to tell you where like
the stages were and those kind of things
mhm so hopefully someone who hears this
is like I can do this and it builds that
kind of like restaurant finder or you
know place find there yeah especially if
you're using Android combining our Maps
API with a our core
it could be really powerful and yeah
just anything we're like data is
overlaid on the physical world around
you I love that awesome well before we
finish up here is there anything that we
haven't managed to mention or anything
you wanna make sure you plug or anything
you just want the audience to know about
before you wrap up you know our
developer advocate team you know we're
always looking for events where we
should you know be at so I am Angela on
Twitter so if you have an event that you
want us to go and talk about Google Maps
or like what you can do we'd be happy to
present that your event Meetup
conference anything so just hit me up on
Twitter fantastic are you gonna be
anywhere in particular in the near
future you want people to know about um
we're still planning out the rest of the
year
so I think the usual suspects like that
chrome dev summit things like that wait
we're here in San Francisco where's the
earth sandwich side of San Francisco
unfortunately I think it's in the water
it's an open sandwich that seems cheap
you could just put bread on anything and
call it an open face sandwich I'm just
saying to think it's that's true you
can't argue that we're generous with
terms here well Angela thank you so much
for joining us on the podcast today and
telling us all about Maps thank you mark
and work thanks thanks to you Angela for
joining us this week on the podcast to
talk about Google Maps really
interesting topic hearing about
real-world locations and how people can
incorporate those in our applications
and their games of course so yeah thanks
so much for joining us and other
creative ideas like a sandwich yes
sandwiches sandwiches are great I do
like a good sandwich it's just it's just
an I think everyone can maybe not
everyone can relate to Maps but everyone
can relate to sandwiches excellent now I
believe you have a question of the week
I do
speaking not of sandwiches but you said
back to kubernetes so we're recently
coming off of kubernetes five year
yep anniversary yeah holiday of creating
they've been around for five years good
time they've been doing some good stuff
yeah it turns out it's pretty popular a
little bit so if you get a chance you
know check out the kubernetes twitter
and the kubernetes podcast twitter which
have a lot of cool content over the past
few weeks about the fifth anniversary
yeah what are the interesting tweets I
saw was you know what's the biggest
concern for kubernetes that people have
and it's pretty clear that the number
one answer is like understanding how to
use kubernetes and as I was thinking
about that I said okay well I've done
some work with kubernetes but a lot of
people have talked about helm and I've
only really really been at the highest
level of helm okay so what the helm what
is it I'm sure that's a jerk no one else
has ever met I has to be the first time
a credit for it thank you
so what is helm why is it important okay
so yes so hollom is an open source
project it's been around for quite a
while actually going to talk primarily
about helm two and we'll talk a little
bit about that later but it is worth
noting we do have an episode way back in
the day episode 50 talking about home
with Michelle new Rowley and Matthew
butcher talking about how in depth but
at its base level it's a package manager
for kubernetes okay so what does that
mean so the thing I like to talk about
when I talk about home is like if you've
ever used apt on Linux or YUM or like
homebrew or anything like that on a Mac
device or chocolaty on Windows basically
it's like how do I install X thing plus
all the dependencies that it has as well
because sometimes things are complicated
and they have lots of stuff and so helm
is really nice in it first of all it has
a series of what they call stable charts
and a chart is the package basically so
if you're like I want to install multi
cluster Redis for example I can go look
for the Redis helm chart there are some
configurable values that I can push
through there and it's gonna go and
cradle the ml that needs to be created
to basically specify okay this is how
the Redis configuration should say set
up you've specified that you want this
many nodes in it and like we can set it
all up and and all the dependencies are
all set up in switch to go so like sweet
awesome and that works well the next
level of that is also how do I either
delete that say I don't want it anymore
and make sure it cleans everything up
but also how do i upgrade it so maybe
there's a new version of the chart
there's a new version of Redis coming
out I want to do something like that now
suddenly I can do a helm upgrade
and it'll do all the nice dependency
changes and all the things I need to
change that way so that I can change
that platform as I need to change it
which is really nice the third version
of that is that you might have an
application yourself and you might be
like oh cool I have this application and
it's dependent on maybe Redis and maybe
several other things so I can set up a
chart with sub charts
I have dependency set up that way as
well maybe there's some configurable
values that kind of stuff so then I can
create a chart specific for my
application I could even publish that
publicly if I wanted to as well so other
people could take advantage you can
actually have multiple repositories
within Helm's so if you want to publish
run charts you can either internally or
publicly and so it handles that sort of
create install upgrade delete lifecycle
of complex kubernetes applications it's
it's pretty nice I quite like it we have
one for the project I work on what works
on a gun is tracks you know when did new
versions come up what version is
currently live what version is available
in the repo pretty comprehensive
I should make note helm three is coming
up so home three is actually a full
rewrite of helm you can still use home -
home - it was great and stable and
wonderful they're getting rid of some
dependencies inside the kubernetes
cluster itself they have a thing called
tiller usually they used to run in there
they're actually taking full advantage
of CR these I don't get any of this
wrong you can actually check all this
out the blog post it's gonna be much
more lightweight installation it's gonna
be really nice but that's been developed
fully in the any open you can check it
all out of github
they were like writing design Docs
before they were any code it's actually
super super cool but the the 3.0 3.0
point-o alpha def one is available if
you want to muck around with it
but ya house really nice I suggest
checking it out it's worth worth having
a look at if you have a complex
kubernetes application you want to
deploy and you're looking for a way to
package that up nicely does that answer
your question mark I think so so let me
let me read that back to you if that's
all right I mean basically you're able
to kind of pull down a chart if you want
to take some kind of a service for
instance like for instance you gave an
example of Redis yep and say I want this
you know in-memory database so you pull
down the chart and you kind of deploy it
and of course if updates get rolled out
of that like a normal package manager
you can say oh there's updates available
so I'm gonna go grab those helm takes
care of all the work there and it helps
to point it out but of course
applications are usually more than one
service yeah right they might be really
complex they might have dependencies
yeah and so you kind of build all that
out plus you're able to kind of take
your own application maybe build it up
with the part that has sub charts and
then push that out there if for instance
the cojones you kind of had
complex tree that you need in order to
deploy the app yeah it ganas is probably
a good example as well I mean we have a
variety of services some deployments a
bunch of our back controls in there as
well and a whole bunch of CR these yes
there's those and things like that and
so that becomes super nice and helm
doesn't really nice job as well of
templating so if you want to have
includes or you want to do loops around
stuff basically be able to generate that
yamo file put it on the fly there's a
lot of nice tooling that allows you to
do that too
so it sounds like a super cool concept
if people are getting started with
kubernetes it might be a great way to
get an application or set of services or
set of deployments or a combination of
all those kind of up I think pretty
quickly and it sounds like people can go
check out the episode 50 in order to see
more of a deep dive yep about helm in
the direction they're going absolutely
very cool yeah I think that handles it
yeah cool all right well before we wrap
up mark what are you up to you go anyway
cool doing a neat content so I just came
back from a long road trip in which I
got to listen to lots of podcasts that
was good so that was a lot of fun and
guising our previous episodes and it's
always fun to go back and listen to hear
the questions that we're talking about
but we do interview some great people so
it's actually super cool to kind of
listen on those and be like wow this is
awesome and then yeah I'm headed to New
York pretty quickly actually I think
maybe even as early as tomorrow
very cool to talk to a couple of
customers and chat with them about their
uses GCP or a little show I do on
YouTube called stack chat where we kind
of interview them about what the
architecture looks like some of the
decisions they get made so it's super
cool to kind of go into these customer
areas and talk to them and be like hey
well why is this important what did you
find along the way yeah definitely check
out your YouTube channel awesome wow
it's all on the Google cloud platform
YouTube check that out that's what about
you I think next on my radar will be
trickier next that'll be in strangely
enough Tokyo oh it's aptly named yeah
aptly named we do name things what they
are generally speaking so what does a
gonna Stu
yeah not I reckon such projects very
different so yeah I Tokyo next in July
so yeah if you're gonna be around Tokyo
make sure to say hello I will be at the
inside event talking about game stuff as
always pretty much fantastic
well mark thank you so much for joining
me on the podcast thank you for having
me mark oh is a pleasure and thank you
all for listening and we'll see you all
next week see ya
[Music]
you